hallo leute willkommen in meinem büro
immer ein ganz bisschen was und zwar
ganz gut sitzen
wie ihr vielleicht auf instagram sehen
konntet und in einem youtube-video hatte
ich ein büro was ich das ganze jahr über
also die ersten zwei monate eingerichtet
haben durch kuranyi ist es jetzt
natürlich so gekommen das teilt sich mit
sophie zeit gebracht habt verbracht habe
und ich dachte mir ich brauche ich das
büro eigentlich wirklich ich habe ja
hier so ein raum und dadurch habe ich
mich dann gegen das büro entschieden
auch wenn ich da so viel zeit investiert
habe das ding ist nämlich ich habe in
meinem büro angefangen zu streamen und
merke wie schön es ist von zu hause aus
zu streamen und ich könnte mir jetzt gar
nicht mehr vorstellen irgendwo
hinzufahren und dann live zu gehen
besonders weil ich jeden tag zeit sport
mache im livestream wäre das einfach
demotivierend und ich würde
wahrscheinlich of screams ausfallen
lassen da mein büro aber hier irgendwie
eher so ein gästezimmer schrägstrich
atelier schrägstrich abstellkammer war
für all mein zeug muss ich natürlich
erst mal auch jetzt hier renovieren
dazu muss ich sagen dass hauptsächlich
miliband farbe sowas von gar nicht mehr
gefällt wir haben das beim einzug
gestrichen
und ich finde es hat so eine ultra
kühlen charakter dieses zimmer hier geht
er in die richtung raus wo keine sonne
scheint das heißt hier ist einfach nur
kalt also die atmosphäre ist kaum team
und ich haben gestern schon das bett
abgebaut was sie hier nicht mehr sehen
könnt wir haben da jemanden gefunden der
das abnimmt und ich bin sehr froh
darüber weil ich es super schade finde
wenn man sachen auf dem bsr hof bringt
wenn sie noch gut sind wir haben auch
möbel vor die haustür gestellt und sie
waren wirklich nach zehn minuten weg was
mich sehr gefreut hat und ich hoffe
jemand freut sich jetzt über ein klacks
regal und billy regal und da jetzt alles
endlich draußen
können wir heute streichen ich habe mich
für zwei farben entschieden einmal real
blau und weiß
denn ich glaube am besten wirkt einfach
weiß in einem büro die wand hinten
soltau werden uni wien sehen
ich habe bock
[Musik]
jetzt sieht es halt so high wir werden
erstmal diese seite streichen und dann
den schreibtischen bisschen bewegen und
dann die andere seite streichen das wird
auf jeden fall ein abenteuer das sagt er
so leute der brust alles nur einmal im
jahr und dieses jahr kein mal wie sie
[Musik]
ich hoffe
abkleben die erste vorbereitung ist das
wichtigste
denn dann muss man nicht aufräumen also
sparen leisten
man könnte jetzt natürlich auch die
steckdose ausnehmen und man kriegt ja
das war noch vom letzten mal kreppband
asse mehr
[Musik]
geschützt jetzt fehlt nur die ganze tür
so die hälfte des zimmers ist abgeklebt
die zweite hälfte noch nicht aber das
ist halt auch sehr schwer mit diesem
ganzen pc und all dem equipment kann man
damit anfangen
es sieht aus als ob ich die stelle
gebührt hätte er das nicht sehen was in
meiner kiste ist das habe ich gehört
jetzt müssen wir streichen richtig bock
also fest wann weiß macht das passiert
jetzt
[Applaus]
amerikas männer messen white collar
motivation ist da
[Musik]
geguckt habe geblockt und man endlich
ist es also noch ein letztes wort wie
heute und mein schluss ach nee das
abziehen ist abziehen musste noch stehen
aber ich würde sagen so kommen wir
hallo kommen wir zum befriedeten teil
des streichens krippen abziehen
[Musik]
jetzt nicht sogar hat doch jeder
das ist der nächste tag mein gesicht
sieht ultra weiß was ist da los ist der
nächste tag die farbe ist trocken sie
ist nicht perfekt geworden das kann ich
schon mal sagen aber ich bin zufrieden
dass meine inneren perfektionisten gehen
und denke mir so das passt schon
ich muss um 12 uhr in diesem raum sport
machen also leicht gehen auf tisch und
er sieht noch nicht so gut aus vor allem
mein schreibtisch
deswegen werde ich jetzt auf sehr
langweilig aber muss sein
[Musik]
diese kabel ich weiß nicht wie ich das
lösen soll
einfach so viele kabel gibt es auch da
ich habe vergessen und es ist mir noch
nie in meinem leben passiert ich habe
vergessen die farbräume zu putzen jetzt
sind sie im arsch bin eine die macht das
immer egal wie müde ich bin getroffen
einfach vergessen
aber ich war auch gestern nicht mehr
ganz hier oben da aufgeräumt werden
jährlich die teppiche reinbringen damit
hier mal nicht
hier können wir bekommen
christian ich habe die couch eingetragen
und es war so sieht sich aus mit
insgesamt aber ging also gut und nicht
die kauft es mir einfach gegen den kopf
gefallen wollte ich das sagen alles gut
guck mal jetzt viele tauschen
egal
[Musik]
so kommt immer noch nicht drauf klar wie
weiß meine haut aussieht was ist los
ich hätte es lieber der kamera unterwegs
ich denke mal so man kann nie genug
teppiche haben pflanzen pflanzen machen
alles besser glaubt mir hört auf eure
mutter
[Musik]
ja ja ja so das bleibt jetzt erstmal so
habe ich entschieden aber fein und jetzt
machen wir gardinen run juhu ich habe
nämlich gardinen im schlafzimmer die so
ein pastell tun haben und die machen sie
mal kurz rein hab die gardine passt sehr
schön ich muss auch also das ding ist
die couch braucht entweder eine decke
drauf oder irgendetwas anderes war
irgendwie wollte ich er in so einen rosa
orange blau
zurückgehen und mit dem grün passt das
nicht ganz so dann hat es mich zum
harten charakter der streifen noch ab
ich weiß
dieser tisch muss auf der fast gar nicht
sind alles nur das sind alles nur
sporadische idee dass dies hier nix nix
ist hier final
ich wollte sowieso mal ein paar neue
sachen besorgen
[Musik]
aber jetzt habe ich schon meine
ätherischen touch hier wieder drin er
muss auch sein co jedoch voran
[Musik]